uh I don't know if you guys can hear me
can you guys hear me fine
why isn't
because I wasn't ready
hold up
can you guys hear the actual
the actual audio
can you hear the actual game
man I know what's going on I have these
this headset on and I bet you there's no
way that you can
is there a way that you can
have it
the settings where it comes out the
speakers too
people got like
TV settings
nah it doesn't look like there's a
setting like that
these Nintendo people man
in the chat
is there a setting like that
can someone enlighten me could someone
tell me if there's a setting like that
mute when headphones are
all right
did that work
that's still not working
hold up
oh my God
I'm I'm surrounded
I'm surrounded by old Tech Guys
Tech that doesn't work the way it's
supposed to
mute when headphones are disconnected
lower Max
uh
it's ridiculous hold on
huh
[Music]
stop getting off the bed honey
I need these
give me a second guys
to deal with this nonsense you guys call
the Nintendo switch
uh
foreign
I just want to point out
that I don't deal with this on the Xbox
Donna taco
I just want to point that out
it is what it is
there we go
[Music]
all right
it should work now
you guys should hear it now
do you hear
do you guys hear what's going on
[Music]
look at all this extra stuff I gotta do
I blame you guys I blame you guys now
I won't have the camera on because I'm
babysitting
so I gotta
[Music]
all right
so I played a little bit of the game
yesterday
we ought to establish a base of
operations before we begin our journey
the somniel would be uniquely useful a
little out of the way isn't it
can't imagine how we'd get everyone
there and back
as a Divine Dragon you can travel there
no matter where you are in the world
I can indeed furthermore one can only
enter the Shadows
without Queen lumera's blessing even we
stewards couldn't have set foot there
that is what makes it a safe haven
well then yes let's use it as our base
but before we depart can you give me oh
it smells nice we'll be gone a while so
I'd like to say goodbye to my mother of
course because
I I just got to the point
why do you we ain't gonna you ain't
gonna bully me into playing
the subs or dubs thank you for watching
me all this time
this journey will be a long one
don't worry
Vander and the others will be right
beside me I will fulfill my duty as the
Divine dragon
I will find all of the Rings just as you
asked and then I'll return to you mother
I promise you guys ain't bowling me what
do you need Kim
here we are
I'm just skipping that
hey hey I was I was doing better last
week like
stop stop trying to say that I wasn't
improving
this is like the academy from three
three houses
I ain't trying to talk to no one I'm
just trying to get into these battles
guys
oh that workout really put put a number
on me man
here we are the kingdom of firenay
what a beautiful place isn't it and no
sign of the corrupted so that's good
that was quite a trip crossing the sea
all the way from lethos I hope you're
not worn out I'm fine good good listen
I'm sorry for twisting your arm to come
with me oh I'm tired guys man that I
wanted to that workout Hit me hard
before we have to talk to every single
character
it's a game oh then I'm not going to get
the essence of the game Donna talk it's
just not for me I'm not doing that
you're not gonna bully me into that
Donna Taco you think you are but you're
controlled by my mother Queen EV we're
known as a Land of Plenty when people
value peace above all else we haven't
seen War for centuries you must come
from a long line of capable leaders or
they're just buying all the safety they
can peace doesn't always come easy
mother had to hammer out a
non-aggression pact with our neighbors
yes he told you the patch says there
won't be war between us Psalm and brodia
right Psalm the queendom of freedom and
brodia can you guys hear uh you've got
it
in the background people you guys hear
that it's pretty loud do I need to turn
that down
they're King's an ambitious man yeah see
you are a mod attacks on Illusions but
we have to be real here we have to be
realistic here Donna Taco I take it in
this round I control all no honestly
they're so far away we don't interact
with them too much we know it's snowy
there with long Winters and that some
Illusions worship the fell Dragon you
fell Dragon it's troubling I know but
people can believe what they believe
sorry I didn't bring it up to turn you
against illusion it's not them I hate
it's the fell dragon
and the one who killed my mother can you
tell me more about the emblem ring that
was entrusted to firenay oh sure it's
the I'm just making sure like this has a
pretty good noise cancellation so I
didn't think you guys could hear it but
I wanted to make sure that you guys
didn't hear it I can't wait to tell my
sister yeah you guys have to worry
ignore my background for the day yeah
you know
I wanted to give you guys the strength
you know first off shout out to Nintendo
for forgiving me looking forward to
meeting a code for this game it's like
one of the first games they've ever
really came together and gave me a code
for that's why I wanted to make sure I
streamed it for you guys uh because you
know you guys know I I generally like
these type of games so I thought it
would be the best for me to play these
type of games because I really enjoyed
them and Nintendo hooked me out with a
code it's like look I want to show you
I'm just not I'm gonna actually cover
your game I'm not gonna just take it and
run and play it I'ma cover it I'ma
stream it I'm gonna review it I'm gonna
do as much as I possibly can
if that makes sense to you guys
oh no
so like I said this is gonna be a stream
I'm gonna play everywhere uh you know
don't get mad if I have to get up
periodically to uh tend to uh attend to
the little girl she needs something I
have to get it for of course
but we should be good if you honor
dangerous yeah she's climbing there on
the background I fear we will never make
it to my brother the internet princess
sailing I beg you to make your retreat
we'll handle this more of the fiends
might be on the way hurry Louie Chloe
you can't possibly expect me to it is
our sworn duty to protect the princess
we will hold the line for you as long as
we must look at all these gold Shields
and stuff
you should fall here who warns Prince
Alfred of the invasion to come they got
all these gold Shields
they're like hold up no wonder that they
can no no wonder they have peace look
how much gold Shields and stuff they
have pains me great I bet you they they
keep booming or even a relatively brief
amount of time might I say I'm a bit
disappointed I didn't get to see you run
off with her highness yourself she got
like a pegasus going on here never leave
his princess aside the sooner we win the
sooner that will come to pass what say
you flow in shall we yes I feel you
barely uh but here's the thing when it
comes to like the writing I don't expect
the writing to be amazing I've never
really expected that
preparing for battle before you begin a
battle you can manage your items emblem
rings and the teams of allies who will
join you once your preparations are
complete select fight to begin battle
[Music]
Alfred
saline what are you doing here I thought
you were with mother I was but Alfred
the elusian Army is what what I cannot
say before they arrived mother sent me
to warn them but then we were ambushed
on our way to Flora port
Louis and Chloe stayed behind so that I
might have a chance to I'll have to keep
the camera off for a couple minutes we
must hurry back to them absolutely
pardon me Princess saline but do you
have the emblem ring yes mother gave it
to me goodness gracious the Divine
dragon how does everyone know what this
dude looks like
I am may I say the emblem ring is right
here please Divine one it is yours
for Words there come care for us emblem
of Echoes
I like how Marth is the the character
[Music]
who is this
red-haired goddess
I am emblem Celica I detest violence but
I will always fight to defend the
innocent
thank you for answering my call
all right I'm gonna put it here because
oh the this the dialogue's always at the
bottom
[Music]
Celica
Phyllis
Divine one with your blessing and hers
of course I would like to fight by
celica's side I must protect the people
of this Village and ensure Louis and
Chloe's safety I entrust this ring to
you Saline
slowly show us and joined your group all
right so look look let's let's have
serious conversation guys let's have a
serious conversation archers everywhere
I understand this gameplay isn't gonna
total a lot I understand this is your
conventional gameplay and a lot of
people don't like this type of game
right through your armor I'm just I'm
rich and Magic so leave the Mages to me
to me it's not so bad protecting each
other indeed this is a nice tune
armored units is now a guard okay all
right so
what I like about this type of gameplay
is I like that
there's a lot of strategic stuff going
on I'm a huge fan of strategic stuff if
you head into battle while connected to
the network Spirits representing other
players past battle may appear on the
map
yellow Spirits appear where many Ally
units have fallen earn XP and bond XP by
waiting in these spaces
purple Spirits appear with mini foes
have fallen way in these spaces to pick
up the items they have fall uh they have
left behind that's cool I like that
uh yes I have permadeaths on I believe
so
look at that house the gate we'd better
warn them to lock up so the corrupted
don't I wonder what happens if uh if you
visit a house to the one in the danger
you may receive items or go as a reward
to visit move an ally to the lit space
in front of the house and in select
visit watch out foes may try to reach
houses before you destroy them
all right we're you're going up here
you no we don't need
The Liberation so
done
over over
[Music]
all right so we got that dude taken care
of
let's
emblem Celica so it was your voice I
heard on the way from the castle I'm
glad you're here with me I feel the same
saline together we will protect things
all right so that's her emblem
was powerful magic attack she is
vulnerable asset against corrupted foes
the sink skill holy stance reflects some
of the damage we received from corrected
foes against the attacker the engaged uh
the engaged weapons deals bonus damage
to corrupted foes the gauge skill Echo
allows a unit to initiate combat twice
using a Tome at the cost of 50 damage so
it looks like you could attack once and
this
it looks like you can attack again
um but it'll be 50 or does it mean like
using that ability is 50 in general
because to me then why don't you just
attack regularly if it becomes 50
because then both attacks is pretty much
just replacing the first one I
appreciate that
the engage attack warp Ragnarok
teleports the user to a space near a
distant enemy and attacks with powerful
Magic
with celica's help I ought to be able to
reach Chloe and Louie more quickly
you can attack one person and then
attack another F okay okay that makes
sense
uh man I can't wait till it comes in on
Tuesday I dumped 129 hours into attack
this ogre and platinum the game
um I had that on on Steam oh I'll tell
you how many hours I had on Steam
shout out to a BG you know he
he hooked me up
he hooked me up that no a lot of you
guys don't like like you know BG and all
them but they've been good to me man
they've been good to me
and I get it they about to smoke ain't
nobody gonna say they ain't about to
smoke but you know they've been really
good to me
hook me up emails to help me get review
codes
sometimes they'll get a review code they
don't need so they'll hook me up with
that
they've been good to me that's why I
always stand by no matter what
I have 209 hours
in um
in Tactics Ogre 209 hours
all right so let's
let's get rid of this corrupt
looks like we're gonna take it straight
down to zero
[Music]
real about stuff like you're not gonna
get a fake BG
like you BG is exactly
what you get is what you see and that's
what a lot of people respect about
beauty
gotcha
all right so she she has a bow
he's a backup fighter I don't know what
backup fighter is exactly are right now
[Music]
um I've beat the game I didn't do any of
the extra like I'm in the
the Palace of the dead right now I'm in
the Palace of the Dead
I don't know if I stream tactics ogre
I don't think I did though
for the Divine dragon
[Music]
uh he's a mage I used him earlier so
he's we're gonna wipe him down here
what's our move
huh
[Music]
hold up guys
yeah I enjoyed Tactics Ogre I really
enjoyed it I thought it was a great game
oh wait come here
um
take the uh
[Music]
all right sorry about that guys I had to
do some business some business
all right so we got this Cavalry goes a
little bit further obviously
we're gonna wait
[Music]
let's visit oh yeah I was supposed to
visit them a minute ago monsters here
take this
oh javelin
[Music]
um
I all right so I I do enjoy
tactics
but there is some issues I had with
tactics I wanted to make a video about
the difference between tactics advanced
and um I mean attack Final Fantasy
Tactics and older but I felt like it
would be unfair until I wait for
potentially that remake that happened
with tactics advance
[Music]
if that makes sense to you guys I feel
like it's not fair to
to do that unless I have that
[Music]
why so people obsessed with my beard on
Twitter on YouTube I get it I need a
trim it man I get it so people get guys
realize I don't I can't trim my own
beard I know make fun of me I don't have
the tools or anything and I'm unemployed
right now well as far as like
appearances go like making sure my beard
is completely trimmed the only time I
actually like pay and go have that done
is like I have a job interviewing
something and you know the these places
they they've been real [__] on me man
they've been real important on me but I
I got a couple interviews next week you
know I had a couple last month but they
they didn't seem that they're that
promises time itself there is a limit to
its power but still to give us a keen
Advantage time Crystal huh so since we
have it I suggest we give it a try
[Music]
the uh the draconic time crystal is now
available
[Music]
through one and retry actions you took
in the battle uh tactic ogre has
something similar to this
foreign
[Music]
got a corrupted cavalry
yeah it is a horse isn't it I'll do my
best let's get rid of him right now
[Music]
yeah it looks like uh we win that fight
he's gotta ax we got a sword like a
little rock paper scissors thing going
on in this game
I won't forget so so Donna taku I'm not
really a huge
so Donna talk I'm not really um
[Music]
big into the
the Fire Emblem three houses was my
first three house I mean uh Fire Emblem
question does um no that's not gonna
work
does what I'm looking for
is Marth like a main character from an
old game I remember seeing him in like
Super Smash Brothers but is he an actual
main character in a game
like Could you
um explain that to me on the in the chat
[Music]
all right let's go up here
actually there's two cavalries down
there let's keep one down here
vulnerability why can't I use the oh
is it was he a main character from older
games
[Music]
okay Marth is the main character I
didn't know if Marth
or Roy from tactics uh from those uh
from what's it called the
Super Smash Brothers
hey Austin
sit down and uh get you some popcorn
[Music]
see you're educating me in the matter I
like how the horses fly in the air it's
pretty lit I'm not gonna lie good
presentation good presentation
foreign
[Music]
Happy New Years
we love it past New Year's but Happy New
Years man
[Music]
let's just go ahead and finish this dude
up we ain't trying to deal with him
later
all right so we got that taken care of
now this is a guardian plus so if I get
a character over there
now we
we're pretty messed up here hold up
let me do this time Crystal I think we
lost someone
no we did okay
there's just this [__] down here is hurt
but I think we're gonna aim for this
dude yeah
[Music]
is it okay
okay
[Music]
let's get rid of this corrupted dude
uh Lucia and chrome were technically not
but they were intrigued to the story of
Fire Emblem Awakening all right where
can I play these old Fire Emblem games
[Music]
vulnerability
yes can
I got you
[Music]
I get back a little bit you know your
mom don't like you in in streams
[Music]
that was uh
all right here
which one you are
what was binding blade blazing blade is
binding blade and blazing blade a game
or or is that like the fighting style he
used
get back cam you know your mom don't
like you in these streams get back
[Music]
I know oh it's a game
I'm listening oh this is pretty rough
over here
I think it's let's move these guys but I
don't know I feel like if I I can't
whatever you require
[Music]
so you can pretty much kill any of these
people with one hit
I feel like this dude's gonna do the
most damage though
all right where can I play these games
guys educate me
can get over there
[Music]
all right your mom gonna get mad when I
tell her you wouldn't listen
[Music]
you're definitely in the camera I can
see
you're fine right there
your mom just don't like you on the
internet
I like how you can get on top of these
uh these castles it's pretty cool
here
[Applause]
[Music]
good damage
we cooking we cook chat we cook it
we're losing ground are we for That
season
police oh we got more okay
reinforcements sometimes call uh even
music custom reinforcement for often
arrive from Forge or the edge of the map
or be on your dog okay
yeah unfortunately you know Nintendo
needs to do better on stuff like that
because I'm not going to say they force
emulation but they definitely make it
harder for people to generally play
their games like people will give you
money for your games Nintendo you just
got to take it upon yourself to actually
you know
offer them that game
I'm gonna move my camera again
[Music]
move it down here I feel like you guys
would rather see the characters than
some stats on the left
if that makes sense
[Music]
I'm gonna keep him there I'm gonna move
her
start getting rid of some of these
pieces
[Music]
this chick's pretty beastly I'm not
gonna lie
she's putting in work
oh they blew up that bridge
[Music]
We're Not Gonna merge them yet
we're gonna hold off on merging
but we are going to get them closer so
they start focusing on other people then
our person there on that castle because
I don't want him getting hurt
what we'll do is we'll get them closer
to our goal
[Music]
all right there we go
all right so
[Music]
I wonder if he came off that could he
take no he can't kill that dude
let's just do another vulnerability
[Music]
it's best to to make sure he don't go
down I recommend Fire Emblem Awakenings
my favorite on 3DS Fire Emblem geology
as the holy war fire emblem Path of
Radiance and radiant Dawn I can
recommend emulator we won't talk about
emulator okay we won't talk about it
eat ing
just message me on Twitter and give me
the recommendations
[Music]
all right so what are we doing here
so there's a corrupted there
it's a mage
[Music]
it's another corrupted
and so
[Music]
let's just go ahead and take this dude
out bows are weak to uh both are
stronger people to fly
[Music]
it got a long way I should have took
more people up this top way
let's catch the fire spell yeah
[Music]
so just out of curiosity did you guys
see uh
me trying to get Cliff Cliff's attention
on Twitter yesterday
[Music]
did you guys see that
did you guys see me trying to get a hold
of Cliff's attention
trying to get cliff on man trying to get
that uh Godfather of Gears of War on the
on the podcast
uh he did follow IOP
uh so you know I'm not that doesn't mean
a hundred percent of anything
but it it's it's a good emblem it's a
good look you know maybe we can actually
get something going on now
foreign
[Music]
yeah I mean if you guys really want to
help you know try to ensure him to come
on you know go on Twitter tag him attack
uh IOP attack all of us and say I would
really like for you to come on the iron
Lords podcast and talk about your book
because I think one of the the caveats
for him coming on is he will be able to
promote his book and I have no problem
the man promoting this book by all means
you're blessing us with uh this guest
appearance if if uh you got a book to to
push we gonna help you push that book
I feel you
[Music]
actually come to think of it
real quick
[Music]
all right so we're pretty good on here
I don't know
my apologies
[Music]
I live to fight again
we'll win this battle
[Music]
strength of the students
all right my bad guys
you suppose there was an important item
you need to rewind
I'm sorry you know she asked me to fix
something on her tablet hold up
said I need to rewind
okay so you're talking about that
let's go back to this
[Music]
we'll visit
thank you for warning me here
oh two thousand dollars good looking out
dog good looking out
but we're gonna let these people run
wild a little bit
so your tail ends
[Music]
yeah Jeff runs loose but you know that's
just who he is all I do with the bows
killer
done over
cannot afford to lose
[Music]
here let me start recording some more
gameplay
[Music]
time
[Laughter]
all right let me look here
trying to keep an eye on everything
[Music]
all right
my bad
oh you're neglecting your own game
it's okay
I won't tell if you don't
[Music]
I don't think this dude can reach over
there but it's probably best to get him
as close as possible
[Music]
he's hurt I've got to hang on
a right and proper end gotta get rid of
her though cause that bow
really put us in a bad spot
[Music]
here until the end
all right let's get closer
got a bonding session going on here
[Music]
for the Divine dragon
I think it did a critical or something
[Music]
I don't think these people are going to
get into battle anytime soon
because it looks like we're about to end
the the people up there are probably
about to take out whoever this Commander
is
soon enough the electric the man who
captured the princess of
oh I like the animation I like the
battles on here they're pretty Epic
let's go child uh childish
[Music]
you know I've really enjoyed streaming I
I've been really contemplating maybe you
know streaming more and more on Twitch
[Music]
instead of just screaming like once or
twice a game
[Music]
stream the majority of the time on
Twitch maybe I'll probably still give
you guys that first stream on the IOP
Channel
but then if you want to see it continue
we'll uh you have to go to Twitch after
that
you know who knows how many of you guys
would come over to Twitch and watch me
but
[Music]
yeah right now you know I I really I
really hope it happens like I said if
you guys really want to to prove a point
go on Twitter
tag
[Music]
okay tag me and tag all of us and
you know really attack Cliff type IOP
tag
Cliff IOP tag all the Lords and say you
know Cliffy I'd really like for you to
come on IOP and uh you know
you know even bring this book in because
you know
if anything what you really can do to
really prove a point and you know
just just just saying chat let's go on
buy his book show a receipt on Twitter
and say I bought your book so you would
come on aisle piece that's all I'm
saying that's all I'm gonna say you know
hey you probably die there is not more
to get to someone to come on than show
and support before they even come on
does he just die automatically
there's like there's like no time frame
that's kind of crazy
can he not move
[Music]
soon enough the election
yeah yeah yeah
[Music]
yeah I'm just saying childish I'm just
saying
[Music]
no I'm not trying to uh change his odds
I'm just trying to get him out of danger
because clearly he's gonna get rocked
I'm assuming the dude with the big
Shield has a more of a chance at
surviving that
[Music]
foreign
yeah that's what I did I put this I put
the shield the dude with the shield
there man
what a lovely
[Music]
lovely I would have won
they've given me real soldiers yeah
[Music]
look at that I wanted any app to do
anything they just did it automatically
that's how you do it that's how you do
it
[Music]
yes just be careful
let me
swing this over here guys
my girl really don't like her daughter
on stream
cutscenes are nice man cutscenes are
nice
[Music]
foreign
there's no need to be afraid it's gone
you've saved my life
thank you it was nothing really I only
did what anyone else would do are you
here by yourself
I am I saw the fighting and thought I
could help
braver than I am
can't stand the corrupted I was so
startled I couldn't think
you really did save my life I see
oh I haven't introduced myself yet I'm
the Divine Dragon what a lovely name
Veil
might I interrupt what is it even with
the corrupted gone it may not be safe
for her out here
perhaps we should escort her home or to
an inn
it's a good idea
hey Vale do you live around here
huh she's gone
Divine One hey guys give me a brief
moment
small with long hair barefoot no I'm
afraid I didn't see anyone matching that
description
okay thanks
did you need something I wanted to thank
you
Alfred told me that you accepted
firenay's request for Aid and your help
in the battle was the difference between
Victory and defeat thank you truly don't
mention it
Alfred and I are friends I was happy to
help friends he said that imagine
speaking so casually with the Divine
dragon please allow me to apologize on
his behalf
is no need to put me on a pedestal
just woke up and the world is new to me
I make mistakes like anyone is that so
I thought surely the Divine Dragon would
be an All-Seeing all-powerful being but
here I find that you are rather more
human than I expected
perhaps we can be friends then what do
you say saline friends I would be
honored
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
let's continue
as you encounter while exploring and
bring them back to insomnia after you
adopt them you can let your animals
grades in the farm line
foreign
[Music]
next to each other who each other or
they'll gain
eventually unlock support conversations
units with support levels gained another
bonus and just stay on adjacent all
right
[Music]
um
yes we will be talking about
about scalebound it is a topic
foreign
I do need to start talking to them even
if I don't care about the conversation
hey folks mind if we bend your ear a
minute
hmm name certain names
and this here's anise purveyor of goods
we saw you trading thumbs with those
things figured you might be in the
market for supplies yes if you need we'd
be happy to provide you with quality
weapons and items anything to defeat
those creatures they pose a terrible
threat to traveling Merchants like us
how would you feel about moving to our
base oh you can sell your way that's
what's going on okay Divine One what we
don't have any facilities these You're
Gonna Let Us open shops at your Bay if
you'd like to we'll need plenty of
weapons and items from here on out it's
a Haven but I bet you and any creatures
there I bet you we still have to pay
can't wait to do business together but
thank you for this I will do my utmost
to ensure you receive the finest items
[Music]
oh it's cool we got 10 G's 10 G's man if
I had ten thousand dollars right now you
know that that's a significant amount of
money to me uh it's not like life
changing
but man I would stop stress if I can
tell you that right now use the world
map to select a destination or move the
next chapter to continue the story move
uh move attic to your next destination
and press a manage your inventory or
return to the center using the menu
all right
I like the world map thing I I really
like the world map thing
we have chapter five chat we're on
chapter five
emblem rings
[Music]
followed by an emblem ring all right so
we can looks like we can give
anyone an emblem ring
do we have some
all right so he doesn't have any does it
look like it looks like racist is attack
Evo and his writing overall
who was that [__]
that was doing crazy damage I think it's
this chick
you know the damage that she was doing
I feel like she deserves a ring and
we'll be real if you could try
[Music]
cigarette I like that name good chat
just just say it with me
sigurd
it's it comes off the tongue really nice
sidgert
[Music]
I am ready Sid guard
might make that a notification chat how
you feel about that every time someone
follows donates you just hear thank you
secret
I think I can get down with that
that I I I I let members of the chat I
let the members of the channel
you know they they say cigarette we just
start we all just start saying cigar
[Music]
got these Rings these Rings look nice
I'm not really a ring person
um
most likely we might mention it
um I I do think that I want to start
yes
one second
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
so it looks like they have skills to
some degree
[Music]
Alpha is pretty cool I like Alfred
foreign
let's just begin the chapter
there's the castle
it's so quiet
where are our Knights or the illusion
soldiers for that matter
you said they were marching toward the
castle when you left
they've probably made their way inside
but then
townsfolk
let's hurry
hate to break it to you Queenie but our
forces have taken the castle this is the
part where you tell me where you've got
the ring stashed in here how does
everybody know about these Rings all of
a sudden who's to say is it inside the
castle out on the ground haven't these
rings looked like I've been around for
for years and years and years I'm not in
the habit of speaking to lowly Vermin
that's all that you are a lot of you
mouth on this one
do you think I will catch it with your
stand
[Music]
oh who is this
I'd recommend against it darling
after all her majesty can't tell us much
of value if she's dead
[Music]
she's looking crazy one of our soldiers
said he spotted the princess fleeing
before we arrived how curious
did you perhaps give that daughter of
yours the ring for safe keeper of course
she did
[Music]
oh well isn't this tragic we'd simply
hate to resort to violence
you leave us no choice by virtue of your
silence we will now kill every living
soul in this castle one by one
please no
uh leave Smitty Smith alone if you if he
ain't fiddling Fire Emblem he ain't been
on fire we're here Alfred saline Oh look
The kids are home
you a Lucian scum get away from her
who's going to make I'm glad you've come
now we can see for ourselves if the
princess has the ring no please leave my
children alone of course as long I ah
young say we'll have to kill her then
pull the prince you actually just kill
her you know you could take the ring you
just gotta kill a conversation later I'm
pretty sure you could take that ring
without killing her
[Music]
foreign
let her go all right enough with The
Dramatics
you
you look familiar uh it's not for
everyone man it couldn't be I really
like these type of games I am the Divine
dragon
such lies Lumera is the last of her kind
shows what you know the Divine one was
asleep for a thousand years really when
did that beastly woman have a child
very well perhaps you can tell me what
happened to Dear Lou Mera then I've been
so worried about her since that awful
battle at neither oh she didn't know
about that how indeed you stole the race
you killed me she died
[Music]
why I didn't kill her I will say you're
coming here was quite helpful because
that means you have them don't I would
say this is a jrpg and the Holy Night
you'll never take them you were after a
ring I won't waste my breath on
excellent the kingdom of illusia has
freed Lord sombron from his imprisonment
who is Lord Sombra I felt dragon has
returned
of course even we couldn't have
accounted for
his return must have awoken you show a
little grab it sure Rock I awoke because
of my mother because she waited for me
all these years a touching tale I'm sure
now if you'll excuse me
[Music]
foreign
wait
what can we do to start we defeat these
soldiers and take I'm not going to let
them hurt Queen EV
get the Rings no prisons I don't know
why I'm liking that look say that really
liking that look
[Music]
all right let's do this let's do this we
got this chat
we we gonna smack him we're gonna smack
him good
[Music]
the door's locked what there's no time
to find the key let's use brute force to
knock it down I like I like homeboy
he's like screw looking we'll just break
it down
as your steward
all right so I can do pretty good amount
of damage I'm all set that don't even
reach him it seems like the camera is
the only people that can actually reach
him
what about this chick I'm listening
uh that's too much damage going on there
all right
[Music]
oh no damage oh hope that old man got
some moves
[Music]
ah
you were a good fight
what's up el Nina yeah Eldon ring is a
jrpg
tactics is a great game I really enjoy
tactics
[Music]
oh so
oh here we go I won't say the game runs
pretty decent to be a switch game
yeah you're right you got a lot of
distance if you engage with them because
he because Cedric is a is a Cavalry so
you you get his movement I suppose
because you become one with the person
[Music]
give me the cotton candy
let me have the cotton candy
you little powder pouting all the time
don't ask for more for a while okay
[Music]
all right let's see here
oh yeah that's they got that 50 attack
don't he
yes
no you can move after he hits
[Music]
my will is firm
all right
I'm not
uh
you know what let's just engage
Network here will probably help me
really a lot right now
[Music]
Fate has brought us here
oh here we go here we go chat
[Music]
uh
your orders please let's go over here
gotcha
I like the bow
s the bows are nice
as your Steward I'm gonna put some dude
down here just for a little backup over
there
apparently there's some Treasure Chest
we can get over there
the Castle's Under Siege Mike
thieves here now
[Music]
yeah actually um we the website Lords of
gaming.net we actually had an exclusive
interview with the uh individual that
made chain that goes so definitely go on
the website and look at that interview
if you guys want to get a little bit
more insight on you know what their
mindset was when they made that
huh
I like the flying
I I messed with the flying I'm not gonna
lie
[Music]
I had to stop you
um
Alfred's Calvary
uh let's
just get a little damaged
I'm enjoying it
level six
too much growth at once it can be a
strain on the system okay
[Music]
guys
I'm sorry
we good we good chat we good we we
moving on up
[Music]
let's move here though so I can jump
these people here in a second
yeah animations for fire is pretty good
I'm a big Stigler on that
[Music]
foreign
oh no damage this old man is a beast
but I do think he's gonna need some
backup so let's get an Archer over there
at least
let's move further there
move him over here
and
and a little bit more backup move him
there
a straight taxi cab would not
have unit levelings up or changing
classes and that's why this is a tactics
RPG is that
called tactics RPG I think there's
another name for these type of games
it might be called a tactics RPG
this is the mission of the stewards
Patrol oh
[Music]
did you see that
strategy RPG and tactics RPG I usually
uh interchange them
I love these type of games dude I got a
bit stronger
I can still fight we could take care of
this dude right now let's just get rid
of all these people
for the defined dragon
[Music]
now let's slice cure because she's gonna
lose her
her form here soon
foreign
I'm curious if we
push her here
can a javelin
[Music]
what hurt both of them
oh no
[Music]
great animation guys great animation
what's up Lord Metro
uh lands power great cost okay okay
let's move back a little bit let's make
them come back out a little bit to
attack her
because the thing is is we don't want
them to stay in a line like that because
they they can reinforce themselves good
over there like we want them to come out
at us
what's up Lord Metro appreciate you guys
showing up man I know it's like I said I
know a lot of people don't like these
type of games but I love these games and
you know when Nintendo sent me a review
code for it I I was a little humbled
yeah because it was just like you know
we've been really grinding guys like you
guys have no idea you know I think some
of you could sit how much that we put a
lot of effort into the podcast
but when Once people like Nintendo
[Music]
you know
feel comfortable giving us a title I
really want to make sure that we do all
we can to show them that we we we want
to cover their products because I I just
that's what
some you know
some people getting the stuff through
multiple variety of things
[Music]
you know some people want to get into
content creation podcasting uh because
they want to get they want to get money
some people want it because they want
the clout they want to fill uh you know
important I do this because I want to
play these games I I want to be part of
the gaming industry I want to play these
games I'd enjoy I do it mainly for the
access because I love playing games and
you know
being able to review a game
thoroughly play it stream a game I think
that is what I've been here for you know
I don't really care about the clouds to
be honest with you guys I don't I don't
I don't really care about a lot of
things when it comes to the uh to the
gaming industry I just like playing the
games
[Music]
depends like right now you know uh I'm
trying to pick my battles when it comes
to because IOP don't get a lot of
reviews
uh our reviews are pretty much funded
entirely by you guys coming in here
super chatting watching the show giving
us ad sync patreon members we're paying
for the majority of these
of these reviews
uh but right now you know we have a lot
of funding coming out for like PAX East
E3 you know we like going to these shows
to give you guys coverage and uh I'm
picking my battles you know right now
thankful was able to get a review code
for this game so I don't really have to
worry about funding this game
but what I like is you know because we
got this game as a review code when I
finished this maybe I'll move on to dead
space or you know when does Hogwarts
come out
[Music]
someone hasn't went
oh yeah this dude
[Music]
February 10th
there's a lot coming out next month guys
actually February was kind of dry for me
but you know like dead space is out here
soon
[Music]
it just depends on what's going on you
know
I I want to cover Dead Space for you
guys too it's probably going to take you
a week to play this game
yeah I will be playing octopie traveler
uh probably reviewing that
store you know I don't even know who to
get a hold of to to get a review code
for that game
oh they
they got me in a little lock over here
[Music]
no
we'll get through this
[Music]
that Rapier
that's a really good move but I'm not
engaged so I can't use it
I had to that sword does really good
damage against uh
against these defense these armored
units but where I don't have it you know
I can't do it but
a
a lance that's pretty good against them
too
[Music]
I'm probably butchering all these names
but you guys know by now
didn't hurt a little bit
[Music]
probably start upgrading their equipment
and Shuffle battles
[Music]
uh
I would pretty much have to team up on
him to do enough damage to hit him
[Music]
yeah oh
javelin
let's take him out
[Music]
simple enough
like a dragon I like the like a dragon
turn-based game I'm not really
feeling
like I don't know because I really like
the
the um
what's that game called
weigh the samurai I really enjoyed
weighing the Samurai and I think
I think I could really get down on uh
away the samurai Style game I know
that's not that type of game but I could
really
get down on that
[Music]
Tech Nine
you know let's go ahead and kill him
I'll take this
battle
God
done for the Divine dragon
[Music]
a riverbane that looks pretty cool it
looks like a lance or something
check it out later
it's kind of a diagonal person
[Music]
yeah let's let's take him out
let me help
done over pretty weak
[Music]
shout out to the 24 people in the chat
watching me play Fire Emblem engage man
I appreciate that hit that like button
if you guys don't mind share this on
Twitter I didn't really promote it too
much because I didn't think there'd be a
lot of people in the community want me
to see plea this over the the top
garbage that people like to call it I
like it you know this is something that
you would see a lot of PC player play
this type of gameplay but I enjoyed this
type of it's it's calming to me
foreign
[Music]
stop playing with him hit him back
see I don't like that
you know
all right so that's a bow
pretty much anything could take him out
[Applause]
[Music]
try shiny for us I don't know what shiny
force is
[Music]
don't worry I'm fine
I don't want to get hit by that
[Music]
oh he's still gonna hit me there
he's a lance cowboy
[Music]
then we got an Archer
covet
is that the faction they belong to yeah
it looks like it's the faction they
belong to there's a thief
[Music]
let's be careful
foreign
[Music]
doing some some damage Man level eight
we level eight chat we we hit a huge
milestone
[Music]
appreciate everyone giving the Love on
my gym picture man I'm just I'm just
trying to be more healthy man you know
right now
where I'm unemployed currently and I
have a lot of free time I think it's
important that I get this
this mindset to go to the gym and stuff
because I feel like
if I'm not going to be able to get it
when I have time to do it I'm never
going to make a priority when I don't
have time to do it I think that's really
important for me to make sure that I get
the mindset to go to the gym daily now
and not once I start my Life Starts
picking up again that makes sense to you
guys I know it probably doesn't
[Music]
Alfred this is the prince dude isn't it
yeah
uh uh we're going back we're gonna start
the player turn again
I just feel like she did more damage
than the rest
yeah I just hit him
[Music]
ow
[Applause]
love weight
[Music]
all right now let's let's finish him
for the Divine dragon
[Music]
okay
all right so let's see here
items we'll go and do a vulnerability
get his health up
[Music]
looks like we can break that wall
we could cut
that's cool destructible walls
uh
take the arrow chick
[Music]
I can still do more
let me
share this stream out to the Twitter
folks
[Music]
let me go to the IOP account
oh I won't share it on the IOP account I
know college just put the marketing up
for um the show tomorrow so I'm gonna
let that go un challenge
uh
uh plan
we'll just have you over here
[Music]
all right let's go this way I Wanda
to get those people off
that there's just this destructible wall
that I think we're going to take
advantage of as well
[Music]
let's bring her this way
because she hasn't engaged yet
so we could use the
to our advantage
armor Slayer
what is armor Slayer
[Music]
ha ha
ha ha ha ha ha
all right let's see here
[Music]
elyrian soldiers
where did these people come from
what are they using
they're using lances
what's the weakness to Lance again do
they got like a
[Music]
I think a sword is weak to Lance
no so that means an ax is weak to Lance
okay there we go what's up loan yeah
look at that damage guys see that damage
chat he loves that damage just
breathe that damage in
[Music]
I feel you man I feel you
we got a lance versus Lance
put across the sticks
[Music]
I got a shield though they don't
look at that look at that hit Nothing
But Metal
[Music]
need some help
Dream well
all right let's see here
we can't get the fire with the book
burn them
oh
I really didn't expect that
can I heal him
[Music]
no that's
I hope that doesn't kill him that would
be unfortunate
[Music]
this chick should be almost engaged
again yeah
all right we're not going to engage yet
we're gonna just move her up
and
I'm gonna do a vulnerability
I think it's really important that we
don't lose anyone this dude I'm worried
about
it looks like he's only got eight HP
left
[Music]
I'm curious how much damage that's gonna
do
[Music]
what's our move
I probably shouldn't have moved him yet
actually yeah I think I'm going to use a
Time Crystal
go back to this
[Music]
I think we could do damage right now
all right
[Music]
this is your vulnerability again just
get her health up
this chick is useless right now
we're gonna we're gonna absolutely
demolish this thief this thief isn't
gonna know what hit him imma get these
objects back he keeps stealing
there was a dude right behind him he
should have hit him
oh thank God
went for the person that I actually
would not mind him hitting
that's wonderful chat
that's wonderful
all right let's see here we got this
dude here he's got a bow so he's
probably he's done
[Music]
more than done
Mater's got an ax and he's surrounded by
a bunch of people
[Music]
can she fly over no
we're gonna get rid of him
this is the mission of the stewards I
wonder if any of the other ones can yeah
okay they can get out
she should be able to get out too
because she can fly
foreign
[Music]
we don't want to destroy that yet
no I don't want to do that
I should have probably kept her where
she was
[Music]
all right let's kill this dude
I'll take this
foreign
level six chat
I see my power uh my training paying off
better keep it up
[Music]
all right
I don't think I can get anything with
that but we're going to anyway
I'm okay let's move him up take a
vulnerability
foreign
[Music]
what do we do now
so we got this thief that think they
slick they not
[Music]
I didn't even have to engage I'm gonna
Overkill
[Music]
here I come
boom
look at that I told you
yeah we'll send that to the Convoy
[Music]
okay
we're good on that
all right so they got a level three Bond
[Music]
foreign
it looks like it might get the main
dude's attention
we're not going to engage yet
[Music]
try to get half their attention he's got
a big Shield
hopefully that will
keep him from getting wrecked too much
[Music]
I sent her up here
she could still engage so we got to keep
that in mind
I will show you no mercy prepare to die
the Divine told you I could probably get
him out kill you
not too bad
this one's a tough opponent
keep on fighting even after taking a
fatal blow
some powerful enemies have Revival
Stones if they're HP Falls to zero they
will consume the stone and revive keep
attacking these enemies until they use
up all their Revival stones
oh
I like how Mars and the main characters
like fighting side by side it's pretty
cool oh
oh
I already got that level up
[Music]
oh gosh look at this guys
let's pop this vulnerability
[Music]
just get rid of this person
pretty weak
oh here we go they didn't see it coming
snuck up behind the chat
who look like a Pepsi logo
[Music]
you have to be more specific than that
someone look like a Pepsi logo
[Music]
you guys are funny
funny people
but Pepsi logos do they have red in them
I don't know if Pepsi logos have red in
them
level up
I I wish I had a Pepsi I don't have one
[Music]
I after this game Kim I will get off
those shiny rings of yours are gonna be
mine no you ain't taking my rings
but this dude ain't gonna play
oh
gee that's right
[Music]
oh man oh man
dodge it
dear
I wonder if he's dead dead I always
[Music]
yeah we can't we can't have that we
going back
are you streaming yes
um
let's try to gain their their aggro up
here
I need to stop DeSoto man I do I'm not
gonna lie
um I'm trying I really am
I am making a little bit of progress but
I can make better progress
[Music]
hey man we should all be that that
healthy to be honest with you
seven
oh he's like that Mage he just straight
up dodged that move
[Music]
bro what oh
hopefully they'll hit him different this
time those shiny brings
[Music]
come on just dodge some of them thank
you
Dodge some of them why are you so easy
to hit
I'm sorry
man getting a bunch of them together can
hit you hard my apologies
thank you
[Music]
we engaging
just make sure we take out everyone but
the boss
we can worry about the boss after we
take out everyone else
Dream well well
[Music]
appreciate it Lord Metro I really
enjoyed that podcast you know Gene
yeah Kim
okay and what
they were like that I remember them
being like we'll fix them in this
question
over everything little girl
all those workouts for nothing oh my God
man
this dude just take out anybody it'll
matter
[Music]
I like the Archer
we'll move on to that
[Music]
lend me your strength can't really I
gotta be careful how I attack
foreign
he was a good a good guy
very informative very
informative he was very entertaining
you know and I I like that he really
enjoys the the streamer aspect
because I feel like a a lot of the time
that's not the case
[Music]
the streamer aspect the
just people in general man people are
shitty in the industry there's so much
gatekeeping that goes on you know it's
disappointing
[Music]
but there's a lot of good people in the
industry too
people that generally want people to do
good
but it's hard to find them man because
people is that
they're saying Wharf and sheep clothing
it's definitely the case for a lot of
scenarios that goes on in the industry
unfortunately
but Gene with Gene talks you can tell he
generally wants the industry to be
better
[Music]
we're gonna engage right now
wart Ragnarok
[Music]
oh I like that
looky here
I am not running this time
warp Ragnarok is the name
he's gonna revive himself unfortunately
I wonder how many he does is that green
thing how many he has access to
um uh we don't need a Time Crystal
we're ending the turn
I like the beef there's some smoke going
with all
man my shoulder hurts
that work got really put a number on me
okay I can't do nothing there can he
could she use that warp Ragnarok again
no it looks like they only use that once
for right now
or is this the echo move
nah we're good
[Music]
oh
level six chat
[Music]
um I'm taking some hits we might be able
to take him out here if he has another
stone that is he might have another
Stone he's pretty weak might have a
couple stones
no it looked like that's all we had
of course he's gonna run though
[Music]
one second cam
one second I'll be with you in one
second
[Music]
Alfred mother is in the back room oh
that's really yeah we showed up and we
thank you did some numbers for rescuing
me my children you're safe it's kind of
crazy we went straight from not knowing
anyone to knowing the queen of a whole
region maybe they should have built this
up a little bit better I have a couple
of battles before we go straight into
saving I've come here by invitation we
didn't really do that it went like
tutorial battle battle saving her
little quick pacing there I would say
absolute pleasure to women yeah it does
have um now the whole game is a voice
act but that's fine as long as you get
the main stuff I'm okay with not hearing
some voice because there's some dialogue
you do have to read but in my opinion so
far it's not been like an extraordinary
amount you know the main stuff seems to
be voice acted and you guys know how I'm
very big on that I want the game to be
voice active versus your mother how is
Queen Lumera she's dead
she's gone
my mother passed away no that's awful
some Intruders entered the castle
they tried to kill me but she gave her
life to protect mine oh
how tragic I'm glad that
that I could spare your children the
pain of losing their mother
[Music]
heart goes out to you forgive me but
we've only just met and here I am laying
my grief at your feet I just wish I
could have saved her too
Divine One
perhaps I can help you bear it
[Music]
reunite with her and then lose her so
soon I can only imagine how painful that
was
yeah it could now allow yourself to
grieve I'll start reading a little bit
more
uh but I am going to start streaming on
my twitch Channel I I enjoy chatting
with you guys like I know a lot of you
don't want to go to Twitch and I respect
that but I do want to save my YouTube
channel for mainly just live streaming
like a like an attic World type of thing
and videos I don't really want to live
stream over there permanently but that
makes sense to you guys I'm sorry Divine
as am I but if I hadn't left when I did
what might have happened to you saline
or you Queen EV I'm proud to serve
people in need like my mother did thank
you now the illusion leader she said her
kingdom released the feldragon I take it
that's why the corrupted are appearing
in Elios again
now there's no question that the fell
dragons after the Rings
which means we need to hurry head them
off before they can reach the next one
Queen EV your country's ring
may I take it
the kingdom of firenay gives it with
love thank you very much there is
something you should know however my
kingdom has another emblem what there is
another race oh she has a secret to
avoid conflict for Generations knowledge
of this ring has been confined I'm still
going to strain the beginning Lloyd
Metro like like these kind of streams
I'm gonna still give you guys my initial
Impressions go over the beginning but if
you want to see me stream uh the
majority of the game it will probably be
on Twitch however firenay received a
second
the Ring of the Dawn Maiden I see to
ensure that no one would find it the
ring was it rests in a shrine On the
brodian Border oh I remember those old I
feel like the voice actor would be a
little bit better though you do
me thereafter father died she
in mind now it makes sense
hiring you for the day you became king
I'll take everyone to the shrine from
there I can continue on with the Divine
Dragon so you Harley yes I want to do my
part to end this war it's probably my
personal one to be honest with you we do
have an IOP one but I want to build my
own streaming brand if you if that makes
sense to you guys Fred
so you have my blessing
I know on one condition
I swear it I swear it thank you very
much Queen how it should be take some
time John it's all good man the journey
ahead will be our Good Fortune make good
fortune shine upon you
[Music]
we got another 10 G's
ten thousand dollars
all right it's probably I'm gonna end
the stream guys but about two hours uh
you know we won't end it right here I'll
probably go to another stream where
we'll just you know talk about what I
played uh but I got the little girl here
and I don't want her being propped up
here we go
yeah it was a good game it was a good
game I can honestly say I really enjoyed
it
uh so far so good you know I don't know
if I'll start these uh like the twitch
thing on these games
uh but be prepared I'm gonna start
really thinking about how I want to like
react to the twitch stuff and do it and
once I give you these initial
Impressions uh then probably the next
time will be on the twitch Channel
uh but I enjoyed it I think
so far
now
three houses has a really crazy twist in
the game and I really enjoyed that twist
I like the engage thing I think you they
didn't make you work for the engage so
far like you pretty much have it from
the start I felt like maybe you should
had to unlock it because it is a pretty
powerful ability
but so far so good I can honestly say so
far so good
um
great example of how to do a sequel you
know three houses was good in a way how
they did a lot of things this seems to
be one narrative story which I like
um you know three houses kind of changed
things up depending on what you did but
this seems like it's it's going to be
one narrative focused and I think that's
extremely important in a lot of games
because when you have one narrative
Focus I personally feel like you can
write a better story but that's just my
opinion but anyway I appreciate everyone
coming out man you guys were up here
like I think almost 30 at one point
watching Fire Emblem
I really enjoyed that uh I will be
making probably what I decide to do
tomorrow on IOP we're having Nick on
we're going to be talking about the
scale bounce stuff we're gonna be
talking about the Halo stuff hope you
guys enjoy it man it's gonna be a crazy
show but